yes Michelle is a literal mind blowing
action movie I want to see it in imax I
haven't seen it in imax but i'm going to
tonight is my first showing in imax 3d
and i honestly cannot obsess on two DS
and my mind would like totally blown i
think my head's was going to like fall
when making to demand and the biggest
scale possible and you know when you are
building a world with so much detail
even the smallest details resonate
figure on the big screen and I think
imax and 3d imax to me is the format to
watch the film on I mean to capture the
full effect of the immersive this you
know of the environment I think I mix is
the best format to see it we had an
inkling that it was going to be cool but
actually seeing it seeing it at imax was
unbelievable even the things that feel
the most kind of like normal becomes
important it's an incredible format it's
just like the immersive experience of
seeing this film and imax 3d must be
just like pure entertainment I think
it's pretty explosive so I'm excited
you